so you're looking at um like this is
life's alphabet right and so I also want
to make a very quick link now to your
first question the Tree of Life
um when when we link when we try to
understand ancient languages right or
the cultures of the or the cultures uh
that use these extinct languages we
start with the modern languages right so
we look at
um Indo-European
languages and and try to understand
certain words and make trees
um to understand you know this is what
uh Slavic word is for snow something
like snig now we jump to languages that
humans spoken humans spoke history
exactly so we make trees to understand
what is the original ancestor what did
they use to say snow and if you have a
lot of cultures who use the word snow
you can imagine that uh it was snowy
that's why they needed that word it's
the same thing for biology right if if
they have some if we understand some
function about it enzyme we can
understand the environment that they
lived in it's it's the similar it's
similar in that sense so now you're
looking at the alphabet for of life in
this case it's not 20 or 25 letters it's
you have four letters so what is really
interesting that stands out to me when I
look at this on the other shell you're
looking at the 20 amino acids that's
composed was life right the one the
methionine that you see that's the start
so the start is always the same to me
that is fascinating that all Life starts
with the same starts there's no other
start code so you sent the uh AG you
know Aug to the cell that when that
information arrives the transition knows
all right I gotta start function is
coming the following this is a chain of
information until the stop code arrives
which are highlighted in black squares
so for people just listening we're
looking at a standard RNA color table
organizing a wheel there's an outer
shell and there's an inner shell all
used in the four letters that we're
talking about and with that we can
compose all of the amino acids and
there's a start and there's a stop and
presumably you put together the the with
these letters you walk around the wheel
to put together with the words the
sentences there yeah where's the
sentences and you you again you get one
start you get three there are three
different ways to stop this one way to
start it and for each letter you have
multiple options so you say you have a
code a the second code can be another a
and even if you mess that up you still
can rescue yourself so you can get for
instance I'm looking at the lysine Decay
you get an A and you get an A and then
you get an A that gives you the lysine
right but if you get an A and if you get
an A and I get a g you still get the
license so there are different
combinations so even if there's an error
we don't know if these are selected
because they were Earnest and somehow
they got locked down we don't know if
there is a mechanism behind this to or
we we certainly don't know this
definitively
but this is informatic uh part of this
and notice that the colors in some
tables too the colors will be coded in a
way that um the the type of the
nucleotide can be similar chemically uh
but the point is that you will still end
up with the same amino acids or
something similar to it even if you mess
up the code do we understand the
mechanism how natural selection
interplays with this resilience to error
so which errors
result in the same
uh the output like the same function and
which don't
uh which actually results in a
dysfunction which are we understand to
some degree the how translation and the
rest of the cell work together
have an error at the translation level
this is the really core level can impact
entire cell but we understand very
little about the evolutionary mechanisms
behind the selection of the system it's
thought to be as one of the hardest
problems in biology and it is still the
Dark Side of biology we even though it
is so essential
so this is uh yeah you're looking at the
language of life so to speak and how
it's can found ways rather to it to
tolerate its own mistakes so the entire
phylogenetic tree
can be like uh deconstructed with this
wheel of language because all the final
letters those are that's the 20 amino
acids that's our alphabet they are all
brought together with these bits of
information right so you when you look
at the genes you're looking at those
four letters when you look at the
proteins you're looking at the 20 amino
acids uh which may be a little easier
way to track the information when we
create
um the tree so using this language we
can describe all life that's lived on
earth
[Music]
we are not that good at it yet right so
in theory this is one way to look at
life on Earth if you're a biologist and
you want to understand how life evolved
uh from a molecular perspective this
would be the way to do it and and this
is what nature narrowed its code down to
so when we think of nitrogen than we
think of carbon when we think of sulfur
it's all in this that the all these
nucleotides are built based on those
elements and this is fundamentally the
informatic perspective exactly that's
that's the informatic perspective and
it's important to emphasize that this is
not engineered by humans this is this
evolved by itself like right humans
didn't invent this just because we were
just describing we're trying to find
trying to describe the language of life
it's it appears to be a highly optimized
chemical and information code
um it it may indicate that a great deal
of chemical Evolution and uh and and
this may indicate that a lot of
selection pressure and darwinian
evolution happened with prior to the
rise of last Universal common ancestor
because this is uh almost a bridge that
connects the early cells to the last
Universal common ancestor okay can you
describe what the heck you just said uh
so this
mechanism evolved before the what
combination so there's the last
Universal case when we talk about the
tree when we think about the root if you
I ideally uh included all the living
information or all the available
information that comes from living
organisms on your tree then it on the
root of your tree lies the last
Universal common ancestor Luca right why
last last Universal because the earlier
Universe it also had trees but they all
died off we call it the last because it
is sort of the first one that we can
track
because we cannot we don't know what we
cannot track right so it's one there's
one organism
that started the whole thing it's more
like a I would think of it as more like
a population a group of organisms I
tweeted this I want to know the accuracy
of my tweet all right
um sometimes early in the morning I I
tweet very pothead like things I said uh
that we all evolved from one
common ancestor that was a single cell
organism 3.5 billion years ago uh
something like this
how how true is that tweet do I need to
delete it no there's actually correct
but I mean uh I I think of course
there's a lot to say which is like we we
don't know exactly uh but what to what
degree is that the the single organism
aspect is that true
um versus multiple organisms um
totally honest yes please
this is how we did like caveats and
tweets right so first of all it's not
um 3.5 is still very conservative
estimate that's what's the first
Direction uh I would say it's 3.8 is
probably safer to say at this point a
bunch of people said it probably went
before if you put an approximately I'll
take that I didn't I just love the idea
that I was once first of all as a single
organism I was once a cell but your
still is you're a group of cells no but
I started from a single cell
me Lex you mean like you versus Luca are
you relating to Luca right now
like your own development my own
development I started from a single cell
it's like it like built up with stuff
okay that and then so that's a first
single biological and then from an
evolutionary perspective the Luca like I
start like my ancestors a single cell
and then here I am sitting half asleep
tweeting
like I started from a single cell
evolved a ton of murder along the way
into the the this like brutal uh search
for adaptation through the
3.5.8 billion so you you defy the code
of Douglas Adams you are proud of your
ancestors and you invite them over to
dinner and you invite them over to your
Twitter yeah so it's amazing that this
intelligence to the degree you can call
it intelligence emerged to be able to
tweet whatever the heck I want yes it's
almost intelligence at the chemical
level and this is also probably one of
the first chemically intelligent system
that evolved by itself in nature yeah
you see that translation isn't it
fundamentally like uh intelligent
mechanism in its own way and and again
the if if we manage to figure out how to
drive uh life's evolution
um in in it can if it can evolve uh a
sophisticated sort of informatic
um processing system like this you may
ask yourself what might chemical systems
be capable of independently doing under
different circumstances
yeah so like locally they're intelligent
locally they don't need the rest of the
shebang like they don't need the big
they need so that that's that's a great
segue into what makes this biological
right the the hearts of the cellular
activities are translation you kill
translation you kill the cell yes you
not only the transition itself you kill
the component that initiates that you
kill the cell you kill you remove the
component that elongates it you kill the
cell so there are many different ways to
disrupt this Machinery they all depart
all the parts are important now it it
can vary across different organisms we
see variation between bacteria versus
eukaryotes versus archaea right so it is
not the same same exact steps but it can
get more crowded as we get closer to
eukaryotes for instance but you are
still Computing about
um 20 amino acids per second right this
is this is what you're generating every
second
that single Machinery is doing 20 a
second 20 years 21 for bacteria I
believe eight four eukaryotes or nine 21
a second I mean that's super inefficient
or super efficient depending on how you
think about it
I think it's great I mean I can yeah but
it's way slower than a computer
could generate it through simulation I I
think if you can show me a computer that
does this we are down here well this is
the big this includes the five things
not just but I could show you a computer
that's doing the informatic right like
yes you can show me that but you cannot
show me the one that has all for now for
now I will ask you about probably what
uh Alpha fold right uh I think the more
we learn about and this is why early
life and origin is also very fascinating
and applicable to many different
disciplines because there's no way you
see this the way we just described it
unless you think about early life and
early geochemistry and uh earliest
emergent systems